we're told that pilar has 85 inches of
ribbon
she gives her friend nico 19 inches of
ribbon
how much ribbon does pilar have left
pause this video and see if you can
figure that out
all right now let's do it together so
pilar is starting with
85 inches of ribbon and i could
represent that
with what's sometimes known as a tape
diagram i guess we could call it a
ribbon diagram
in this case so let's say the width
of this rectangle or this tape or this
ribbon
represents the length of pilar's ribbon
so this is 85 inches
of ribbon right over here she gives her
friend
nico 19 inches of the ribbon i'll do
that in red
so gives away 19 inches so i could think
about giving away
19 inches and this is just i'm not doing
it exactly but you get a sense of things
so 19 inches might be about
that much so that's 19 inches
that pilar gives away so how much ribbon
does pilar have left
well it would be this section right
over here now how do we figure out
how much she has left this question mark
right over here
well there's a couple of ways to think
about it you could say 19
plus the question mark is equal to 85
let me write that down
19 plus question mark
plus what we're trying to figure out is
equal to
85. so the amount she gave away plus the
amount she has left is equal to 85
or you could say if i start with 85 and
if i were to take away 19
well that's what i have left so you
could also say
that question mark the amount that she
has left
is equal to 85 minus
minus 19. so what is 85
minus 19 well there's a bunch of ways
that we can compute it one way to do it
is i could rewrite
85 as 80 plus
5 separate essentially the tens place
from the ones place
we have eight tens which is the same
thing as 80 and then five ones
and then rewrite 19 as 10 and 9. so if
i'm subtracting
19 i'm really subtracting 10
and subtracting 9. now why is that
useful
well it's pretty straightforward to say
that all right
80 minus 10 is going to be equal to 70.
8 tens minus 110 is going to be equal to
7 tens
and so i could rewrite this as 70
plus 5 minus 9.
now if i just try to figure out what 5
minus 9 is we get into a little bit of
trouble because 9 is bigger than 5. but
what if we were to rewrite
9 in 2 parts if we were to say look 9 is
the same thing as
4 plus 5. so if i'm subtracting 9 that's
the same thing as
subtracting 5 and then subtracting
4. and this makes it a little bit easier
because we know what that 5 minus 5 is 0
and so we can rewrite this as 70
minus 4. now what's that going to be
well we know that 10 minus 4 is equal to
6 so 70 minus 4 is
going to be equal to 66
and we're all done that's how much
ribbon she has 66
inches of ribbon left